e
do I'm gonna open the uh work session
1485 good all right want me do that yeah
oh yeah you got a much better knock than
me yeah I used to break
po back in the old days
so this was an act establishing a study
committee for the totality of
circumstances surrounding the covid-19
pandemic
um I I get it right here if anybody
wants to read it it's it's pretty simple
right want set up a commission y my
understanding yeah three members of the
House appointed by the the the speaker
one by the Senate by the president of
the Senate one appointed by the governor
the idea here is that uh from uh
speaking with the bill uh Prime sponsor
he mentioned that we already have a a
there is an somewhat of an existing
version of this that's covering kind of
how the state of New Hampshire handled
it the idea for buying this bill was to
see how the um like interactions between
the federal governments and like
non-governmental organizations whatever
whether they be pharmaceutical
Industries or International
organizations like the World Health
Organization and uh un Etc like may have
had influence over policy decisions made
here at the state level and how they may
have filtered down to the schools Etc um
there's a whole list of things yep that
they wanted to protect potentially cover
here like and it's like covering
everything from like operation War speed
whether that was handled censorship
efforts that were done by big Tech
during the time um that we saw from like
Twitter files things like that coming
out uh especially the federal government
putting the their thumb on the scales uh
the FBI in particular um as with like I
think a lot of these study committees I
don't know how much we can glean from
like the federal level like how like
we're not going to be able it's another
study committee it's another study
committee um we' got a ton of those
right um
what's what's the breakdown the
breakdown is three from the house one
from the Senate one from the governor um
it's not as broad like I know when we
get to the um the this one has to be
amended when we get to the uh the
Liberty Bill like that one was like a
gigantic commission with all kinds of
international individuals this is
straightforward this is something that I
think we can handle uh I don't know how
much information we're going to be able
to gain from like uh you know asking the
federal government hey did you guys
censor things and whether or not they'll
be honest with us but uh it would be we
could of course ask like uh you know
hospitals like whether there was a
coercion from the feds with Medicare
funding or any other kind of funding
whether it be in the schools like for
compliance persuasion yeah of course
yeah persuasion from the federal
government or other
bill so I I'm inclined to uh recommend
for further study uh I don't see any
harm stud for legislation for the
legislation for yeah exactly I have no
problem with that inine you incline mhm
so vote yeah we we could vote as a
subcommittee like uh yeah do you want to
call the role I guess sure thank you
okay so you're making recommendation for
further reg legisl future legislation
yeah
yeah I think it'll be for you okay I
sub committee voted unanimously to
recommend further
legisl reced something whatever
the okay and how do we vote uh I
I and
and I'll vote with you car get a vote 40
voted un all right cool so uh we'll CL
you want to knock we'll close the work
session on 1485 and we'll open the work
session on uh HB 1041 this is the uh
relative to establishing a commission to
investigate the USS Liberty incident and
its
aftermath um so uh I have spoken to like
some of the activists with this and the
Bill's Prime sponsor and uh I remember
the representative shift did bring point
out that some of the members of this the
as written were problem IC we probably
don't want like this International organ
like some of these International
organizations uh I have seen language
that was floated to me after we already
like interim studied this so like
there's there's a path forward for this
that I think requires uh scoping it down
to something similar to just like 1485
that we just did something that's like
House and Senate and perhaps anybody
else that wants to be involved whether
it be like uh the American Legion or any
of these other or veterans organizations
in the state maybe somebody from esvac
we can tap to come and be a member that
that can represent the veteran Community
as a whole
uh but I mean that's up for the the
whoever the bill writer is I I think
there's a lot of Merit with this bill
um I personally I believe that the
federal government uh didn't do these
men Justice uh the the entire
investigation I think they said lasted
like a week or so like there have been
things like a stain on aess that took
months and months and months of
Investigation at the federal level and
here we're talking about service members
that were poent that were killed by a
friendly fire incident got like less
than a week of Investigation swept under
the rug um I think that's a travesty and
I feel like it you this happened in 1967
these men aren't getting any younger and
it' be great to bring these guys up
before anything like my age level get
them on the record get them tell their
side of the story and we could try to
get to the bottom as best we can as a
state uh once again we're going to run
into the same roadblocks trying to ask
the federal government for to be for
transparency or information that they
have it'd be fantastic as you had
mentioned earlier that if we get like
the our federal delegation to perhaps
help us um in this I I don't you know I
know that when this was filed there was
there had just been attacks in Israel so
there was like a some of this felt like
uh bad timing but this is something this
goes back this is from the 60s like this
is an incident that happened a long time
ago federal government looks the other
way they feel like a lot of people
believe this to be a settled issue but
it's only because the federal government
swept it under the rug and uh we got
some kind of apology from Israel that
doesn't justif that doesn't give osure
to these men that experienced this then
were ultimately betrayed by the federal
government when it came to getting
Justice that they deserve or at least
acknowledgement a thorough investigation
to find all the people potentially
responsible for this a lot of suspicious
consequences yep thank
you do want to do the mic I don't know
if this being broadcast I don't see the
camer I don't know I guess I'm not sure
they report any anyway all I know from
ship the Personnel on that ship the most
decorated ship in the
navor the Israelis paid Millions upon
millions of dollars in
reparation there were two Congressional
Medal of Honor winners on that ship an
unarmed ship that couldn't fight back
why did they do that plenty of multiple
silver
stars uh why was that done you trying to
buy the
silence I've been in the Navy I've been
on ship but I was on a fighting ship a
destroyer and we could at least fight
back and supposedly Israel I'm pro
Israel 100% however in my opinion what I
see you don't
strafe
um a friendly a friendly country to to
you you don't Strife the the sailors
that are on their lifeboats because the
ship is sinking MH and you don't stra
they went after the Japanese in World
War II for doing just that yeah so uh I
think this was egregious on the Israelis
part but my thoughts were what gave them
the idea that they could do that and get
away with it do completely without any
push back from a friendly nation which
the United States was what was the
Liberty doing it's a spice ship all you
unarmed not one gun on the SP ship
usually sometimes they have an escort
but most of the time they go alone well
what were they doing in the war zone to
gather information for what and what was
the excuse I know the size of a flag on
a on a ship that's moving that that's
underway that the flag is very very
visible from I was a signalman and they
and even without binoculars from about
maybe three miles away I could see that
flag because it it was almost as big as
this as as tables there a couple of
these tables put together and you can we
had to know how be able to identify
which flag from which country yeah and
so the
Israelis I don't care how fast you're
going in those Jets you see that flag
yeah the PT boats see that flag clearly
the testimony I see this guy right here
there's no place to go where you going
to hide you go to below deck you get
steel shrap you're done or you take it
you take my water so I'm f in favor of
recommending this for further
legislation with the recommendation that
our uh Federal delegation gets involved
in this they're the only ones that are
going to have the clout to be able to to
to maybe get any answers we won't we're
just I'm just talking in the wind right
now yeah we can have the men come and
testify again get it on the record but
that's like I think that's the limit of
our abilities they may show up for the
exec session yeah yep they may but but
my recommendation if you need a
recommendation from someone is that uh
this is recommended
for future
legislation and and including uh a
request that our federal delegation gets
involved in this if they don't know
about it now agree make it known to them
I agree I agree with everything is said
I was talking with someone and they said
will this though open up committee to a
lot of other things that happened that
would we just way back when and will we
be bombarded by it because of the fact
that we did it for one now we expect
to if it I would say I mean I could
understand that
the would you like anything that the US
has potentially been involved in like
elsewhere I mean uh and then it falls on
the it'd be up to us to file it right
like we like anybody could file anything
so if somebody wanted to file it I mean
we could hear it out and I think each
one of those like depending on what it
is perhaps it has Merit like I don't
know like a lot of these things like we
can't I think after the first couple of
these where it's like well we can't
really do anything we're just going to
do an information gathering thing right
go from there and hope the TS pick it up
yeah so I think after the results of
something like this they'll be like well
you know we got it on record we did what
we could do but it's not like we could
we we as a state cannot necessarily hold
a form country you know responsible so
like nothing's gonna happen so they can
file future bills based off of the
precedent of filing this one but I don't
know what they may not see value in it
um I don't I don't necessarily worry
about it we can debate it here as this
it'll probably come to us I have no
problem debating anything that anybody
wants to file something along those
lines there may be Merit who knows yeah
I just want to bring that forward
because that was valid concern said
especially if it's within the United
States involving another country then
are we will like right yeah my because I
agree with what you said my only concern
is is is yeah my concern is
that keep thinking
that
a an ally does not attack another Ally
without no there no argument what was
the reasoning behind it that's yeah
sticking in my because these guys I'm 80
years old so these guys are are probably
in the late 70s and into their 80s some
of them are barely walking right so I I
can understand what and I was on a
warship you could fight back these guys
couldn't fight back there's the flag hey
this's a star of David there're our
allies right yeah and I'm getting shot
at there's nothing I can do about this
this would almost make a very good Ken
Burns type document and that would get
it to the public so much better who
knows Ken than a committee you know
report yeah that's it's true because
it's you know a lot of things like that
out there what struck me at a very
emotional level was the v's coming and
testifying to us and I didn't want to
give them false hope about what we could
do to change their situation yes that
that has to I think be very clear like
there's not much we can do we can't
necessarily hold anybody blow off
exactly yeah
uh I keep looking at this picture and
I'm haunted I I got about three hours
sleep last night because I knew we were
going to appear today and I know what
it's like there's no place to go no
place to hide I was on a on the signal
bridge above the Pilot House on the
Destroyer my the used to the the bean
counters would say that my you know in
the gunfight in know right in a battle
my survivability rate would be like 35
seconds y you know but when you're 20
years old you're going to live forever
yeah right doesn't get you until it hits
you until it gets you so is there any
federal committee or whatever that
grievances like this can be brought to
them or do they not have anything like
they have a
federal I'm not armed services committee
there is an armed services committee I
don't know it would probably be this and
like through the VA like you'd have to
probably like work with the Veterans
Administration to see what what they
could do like but it would have to be
something similar to like what we're
doing here theyd probably have to form
something specific about this incident I
was just wondering Ted should have
something that we could say okay we're
recommending this um for you know future
legislation but that it can move on to
the next step which would be yeah
whatever I mean as opposed to getting to
a
wall well there's uh standards of
they each have grievances reviews you
know boards but is that more about like
interm militaries yeah it is to
me if I really wanted to make change now
I would talk to someone like a Ken Burns
and say listen these people are still
alive get their story while they're here
because I will tell you I I couldn't
leave my seat listening to what they had
to say oh I know and I was close to
tears I actually was close to tears they
are the best Advocates that exist yeah
and telling their story is the best way
to get people to understand and demand
change it's good idea we'll work on that
yeah I know I'm looking at I'm looking
at the review boards like I just don't
think this is going to go
anywhere the one thing about so them
coming before us like raise their
profile and perhaps like if if we do go
ahead with the legislation on this in
the future that would also raise the
profile it's things like that you have
to just keep mentioning it so it doesn't
disappear put it yeah right put a bird
in the
saddle of the
federal those responsible I'm I'm sure
that
that the ones who made the
decisions
to squash
this most of them are dead now oh oh
yeah we're talking 67 yeah you know the
guys who were Admiral back then were in
their 50s and 60s yeah they're not I
think they're gone so right so anybody
who's trying tose we have to stir the
ashes yeah but this this this is the one
that
really the report from the
ja where the time was a a full bird
Captain where
is this guy right here yeah David
Lewis and all this information they want
to give him like days
to put something together M and then
when they were ready to
go to the uh what do they call that an
inquiry an inquiry na inquiry that uh
they were told by the one who was the
Admiral the four star who was in
responsible for that theater of
operations at six or seven I think uh
told me squash it but we have this this
this information you do
not it's horrible you do not yeah and he
he didn't make that decision on his own
no a fourstar takes his orders from guys
in suits y
yeah so that's uh that's my two sets oh
that's
good I mean I so I would like to make a
motion to recommend for future
legislation you need yeah I'm not sure
unanimous this yes
yeah because I assume when we meet again
after veto day we're going to just go
over what we discovered bring
awesome um my wife said what's the
problem I says I'm going to a sub
M on this and she had seen this before
Oh picture that guy with bur burn face
say
yeah the year before I was like in that
neighborhood
yeah you going to call the road I am you
ready yep okay Manion yes okay gagy yes
and M mow yes and I'll say yes too all
right now could you read back what the
the
official um what we're recommending so
Manion makes a motion to recommend for
further future legislation but up here
in the
discussion um we talked about the
inadequate investigation back in
1967 statement of concerned getting
information from the federal government
and felt our federal delegation should
request a proper investigation beautiful
okay if he can get a hold of somebody if
can
get a hold of some of these people
survivors oh yeah and get a hold of the
uh the survivors of the Dead this guy is
dead but I'm sure there the family
probably has all kinds of notes and
archives yeah that I think that would
make I would I would definitely watch
that yeah and for future if we do the
they refile this amend it like one of
the uh guidelines of the the committee
could be whatever report we generate is
sent to the federal delegation yeah we
could do that that could be written in
the in the future Bill all right so I
guess with that we can uh close the the
work session on
10:41 youate a motion to adjourn uh
motion to adjourn so moved all right
thank you thank you thank you guys for